адже тисяча було сил дортмунді слухати
вони називають не інакше як соком команда
клубу в акриловому автобусі
їхало з пляшкою на стадіон для участі
побачити людина фіналу ліги чемпіонів
біляус бича програмі чи трібуха та
детонацію вкотре було секула на бубна і
сварку футболіста марка бартеру пролом
руки та шпильки прани дня його
прооперували
акустичну хуевую пору на поліцейського
і щура проводять живий автобус поле
тексту на вулиці атака самий на крафті
борусії
анонімів рибах і про час падали в
готелі в якому за панелі ся боруссія ядро
забула відразу мило серце билося прямого
наото кана команду кинули всі сили
поліції підняли по тривозі фон anfang він
без ніші стала відома ще на місці зло
Чи знаєш записку за позбавлено не буду
злом і з на кому і низько німецьких змі
передаєте з місць і ми вірно ланцюгом сни
ісламістів заучи знімати якісь такі
торнадо в операціях проти бойовиків
ісламську державу ви раку а також купе
реджине для ангели маркою таза я вашу
видами люду немічений тепер стало тіло
ми королю стив якщо ви бухих піди
розвивався стрим до поліції, адже провал
футболіст cubase пекти на місці хоча
стадіон вже буде заповнено людьми
кривенкова руси кутку чую матч перенесення
на доступну данину біля бульвару корус Павло
та про атмосферу солідарності на арені
фанати монако спочатку по людині
голосувати їм молекули зізналася а в
чим у праворуч ми всі об'єднувалися і ми в
ситце європа он і за suju терактах
самі фанати борусії
клуб булево нікому на коді знала ще й
дайте про 1 футболістів команди
супер на кого але чому сканда ватага
слабо руси ще 53 ми-то дартмуті
[оплески]
вусики багатих були валянки в монако для
планувала зал шатохіна нішу дортмунде
їх гривні 100 футбольного клубу боруссія
запустила акцію з хештегом bed of life
and correct одіозно чаю надлишку для
фанатів з далеко сотні німці в
соціальних мері крок за пропливала на
знайомому бульвар ніком монако
безкоштовно передачу від aussiebum вдома
забрала їх на око на автомобілях та на
адже оплачувала таксі обидва вечори у змій
назвала c одні з на та масштаб нижчих
акції солідарності футболі за астану
ярок і
але розслідування нападу на брусі відразу
підключилася прокуратура свічки
підтвердили версію ісламістського сліду